[Musique]
une
chose est depuis combien de temps et tu
fan de johnny hallyday
femme depuis huit ans ne peut que johnny
a sorti son premier
oui
[Musique]
j'ai beaucoup pensé à ses gonds c'est
tout ça c'est ta collection oui
et ça c'est quoi
ces dix cartouches que 2000 quand j
avais tiré à la carabine à romain son
jeu
je ne sais pas je peux pas les compter
parce que toutes mes photos sont signées
à toutes les photos que j'ai que je
prenais en noir et blanc il ya quatre
ans ont signé tous mes disques aussi
je sais pas je me suis jamais il ya
environ 2000 premier des signatures en
ont
bien combien de photos la
2000 à peu près et pourquoi je n'y
allais dsk sème billère mais pourquoi
encore
parce que je trouve que le fanatisme en
france peut exister que pour le génial y
des jeux valve a dit qu'est ce que c'est
que ça vous intéresse c'est à dire
je sais pas une idole une idole
en france il ya que johnny avant mais là
tout pour être une idole je vois mal un
autre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
c'est plus qu'un chanteur c'est un
personnage sur scène il est inégalable
pourquoi parce que je crois que xpress
j'ai un peu été voir tout le monde parce
que tout le monde m'a dit que j'étais
aveuglée et je me suis rendu compte
que vraiment il n'ya pas qu'ils aiment
autant son métier que sur scène je crois
que johnny
il vit plus sur scène
que dans la vie
on voit aussitôt qu'ils rentrent en
scène où j'ai même mois remarqué quand
quand ça faisait un certain moment qu'il
n'avait pas chanté le premier spectacle
qui faisait après vraiment là il était
déchaîné
on voit qu'il adore ça vraiment que le
petit chanteur qui fait son spectacle il
chante le nombre de chansons tout le
monde applaudit reviens parce que c'est
calculé mais johnny si on l'applaudît si
ça marche il restera le temps qu'il faut
moi je n'ai vu déjà resté deux heures
sur scène
il s'épuise complètement je trouve ça
formidable
sally des joies mal
je vois mal la chanson
tu doutes du mois le côté scénique
[Musique]
dijon
thomas
[Musique]
à
et m
mais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je trouve qu'il est beau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et cette chemise et cravate et chemise
c'est johnny qui m'a donné à l'olympia
67 et les cravates aussi je les ai vus à
cette l1 pia nous avons conçu remonter
sur scène les chercher ou bien ils les
achetez le ah oui il y en a que j'ai eu
quand il a acheté mes enfants d'avoir
une quand il la jette
c'est pas très facile à mais tu t'es
battu pour l'avoir une fois je me suis
battu pour une mais les autres je
mentais je savais à quel moment ils
achetaient et je monte vite avant
est-ce que tu fuis en quelque sorte sa
vie
c'est à dire que tu m'intéresses par la
force des choses parce que je vois
tellement souvent que
enfin toute façon il n'y a pas de
problème alors y'a pas de problème c'est
à dire il n'y a pas de problème ou
johnny une femme un fils c'est tout ce
que tu aimerais te marier un jour avec
quelqu'un qui ressemble à johnny
hallyday en absolument pourquoi parce
que janis et jenny une copie de johnny
c'est plus lui non
[Musique]
j'ai déjà pensé beaucoup à ça
j'ai déjà eu des fleurs je crois qu'on y
pense quand on connaît pas tu as déjà eu
l'effort
ça me regarde pas
demain
on a l'impression que je n'ai à l'idée
souffre sur scène crois tu que c'est
vraiment sincère
[Musique]
je pense oui en partie parce que pour ça
je ne crois pas qu'il sera capable de
faire ce qu'il fait je pense quand même
qu'il reçoit un petit peu
vous dire que c'est un bon comédien
aussi
mais quand même je crois quoi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quelle a été la réaction de tes parents
tu devenu fan du jeune élite et
pro c'est absolument pas grave ça se
passera
il ya 14 ans ça se passera à 16 aussi et
maintenant ils pensent plus rien
pourquoi parce que
qu'est la profession de ton père il est
employé aux magouilles tamer îles
maritimes
et tu n'as jamais rencontré le problème
d'argent pour aller voir jeunes et voici
alors ça énormément c'est à dire que
souvent quand j'achète beaucoup de
photos déjà tous les livres il paraît
c'est énorme et alors le 10 du mois je
passe ou alors avec mon amie on sent
prêt de quoi on a des tas de problèmes
surtout pour les photos ça reviendra
trasher de prendre des photos on les
prend en couleurs tu mets tout l'argent
de poche de douane on
tue des pneus mais pas mal les trois
quarts d'heure
quel est ton poids actuellement je
travaille dans une agence de publicité
depuis longtemps puis à moi du travail
des commentaires
depuis trois ans d'abord avant j'étais
des études commerciales pour passer mon
ca fait d'être contente du étant certain
de
la part de qui monsieur oui je vous la
voix de maratha sans faute avec le
rectificatif on va monsieur
comment fais tu pour suivre géniale idée
à 12 ans puis à 14 ans puis aujourd'hui
et bien c'est toujours débrouillé
c'est à dire
c'est à dire j'y allais en voiture en
train ou en voiture quelle voiture
la vie des amis oif tôt oui ça m'est
arrivé
je le suis souvent en a parmi très
souvent et en province beaucoup moins
mais à paris très très souvent aussi de
qui fait une mission qu'il enregistre un
disque n'importe quoi j
le samedi le dimanche je fais tout
ça dépend de ce que fait de génie si je
sais qu'il fait quelque chose
mais enfin sur les personnes qui
entourent john il ya des personnes très
bien
toute manière je crois que la personne
la plus intéressant dans cette demande
c'est johnny mais on dit toujours tous
les diriger qu'il est mené par le bout
du nez mais je crois que c'est ce qui
fait
[Musique]
si il signe un contrat pour ça là où là
il sait pourquoi il fera ça lui même
c'est très bien
[Musique]
c'est les fans
je crois que le phénomène de fan ça a
commencé entre dans l'amérique
des artistes d'avant guerre
et ensuite c'est venu en europe
[Musique]
et je crois que ça se
savent à quel certains genres d'époque
c'est lui en france c'est bien je me
rappelle c'est venu en france d'abord et
que gimd
il comptait un genre de mouvements de
femmes donc moi je faisais partie
pizza plus ça continue avec des
rock'n'roll mais non il faut pas
confondre dix enfants et fort ils ont
mis à l'effort comme je pense que c'est
beaucoup plus fort des femmes qui du
rock'n'roll par exemple que des
générateurs de chansons différentes du
rock'n'roll parce que les admirateurs
c'est pas des formes sont les gens qui
apprécient mais ils vont en spectacle
pour apprécier écouter ou voir quelque
chose qu'ils aiment bien alors qu'ils ne
s'adonnent pas entièrement ça vous
dirait une faction gens du théâtre c'est
fini pour eux ils ont des produits
patients la caf en hammami dépenses en
tout cas plusieurs heures de leur
journée à collectionner les photos
penser à leurs artistes préférés
[Musique]
autour de toi
ça te gêne pas pour jouer
je vois ça me gêne
[Musique]
oui parce que moi ça m'enlève tout
en anglais seront dix à rêvasser
côté intime de ma vie privée je n'ai pas
entendu
il n'a pas l'impression qu'ils perdent
leur temps parfois
moi je ne sais pas je suis pas fan de
neige
cher johnny tout d'abord je te dis ma
désapprobation et mon indignation ainsi
de tous mes amis pour le 15 août selon
certains tu n'as pas fêter le double
anniversaire que sylvie attendait avec
espoir que tu viendrais mais tu étais
entraîner par tes sales autres copains
oui tu veut sacrifier ton bonheur aux
conneries que tu écopes pas rappelles-tu
des paroles entre mes mains tout ce
bruit l'amour est plus fragile qu'un
jouet alors pense à sylvie à l'honneur
de son fils davy
jours ici si seulement le destin pouvait
faire côté lise la mienne et même la
prenne au sérieux si tu savais johnny
comme je suis malheureux rien ne
m'intéresse sauf la musique et surtout
mon rêve pouvoir un jour jouer de la
batterie
dès que j'entends une chanson surtout
non pas par hypocrisie une chanson de
johnny hallyday je n'arrive plus à me
retenir je sens que j'ai la musique dans
la peau
[Musique]
je nie mon amour je t'aime tu sais
aux jo ni si tu savais comme tu me plais
tu es beau tu adores aux yeux je t'adore
tu vas peut-être penser que je suis
folle oui je suis folle de bonheur
manger et or personne m
personne
[Musique]
autant personne
mais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette jeune fille semble vraiment
illustré à la fois les phases
psychologique de l'adolescent s'est
particulièrement des difficultés de
l'adolescence féminine et ensuite elle
incarna c'est bien une certaine période
de la jeunesse vis-à-vis d idole de
toute une histoire du show business et
même de la carrière de johnny lui-même
c'est une jeune fille qui a peur de
l'amour c'est évident est la peur du
réel et elle est d'ailleurs extrêmement
pudique elle refuse de vous parler tout
à fait de sa vie privée je crois que
peut-être elle n'a pas
presque pas peut-être ne veut pas le
dire de toute manière ça la gêne de
parler du réel
cela gêne aussi de parler de la vie
privée de johnny hallyday elle fait
vraiment une coupure et elle apprécie
que lui ne vivent qu'en seine
comme elle ne vit que dans une limite
hic tous les deux ils se rencontrent
justement par cette espèce de faculté à
s'épanouir tout à fait dans un monde
coupé de la vie de tous les jours
[Applaudissements]
ouais
[Musique]
moi je t'aime